[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar making therapeutic antibodies
simple fast and safe
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by genscript to learn more visit
jenscript.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr ladan ding head of antibody
department gen script dr dean you may
now begin your presentation
hello everyone my name is
i'm come from jin script it is my great
honor to be here and sharing our
experience on the therapeutic antibody
discovery projects
firstly i will briefly introduce gene
script
here is the history and mastery of gene
from the roadmap team scripted keeping
activity to develop long tunneling
platform teamscript was funded funded in
new jersey us 2002 and then we
established europe and asia-pacific
division to facilitate global service in
2019
and the last year we successfully
established a new rd and production
facility in singapore and a new cell
engineering and the various production
center in shanghai
and a new house report facility in the
u.s
and on the other hand specifically for
the antibody service platform we
established the customized annual
service in 2004 and until now we have
gained more than 18 years appearance on
animal discovery
back to today's topic for therapeutic
anabolic discovery thin scripture can
provide one-stop solution from antiquing
design gene and the peptide synthesis
protein production to antibody discovery
we can also provide antibody engineering
such as humanization affinity modulation
gmp grade cdmo service and the invisible
and individual pharmacology and
characterization of antibodies
today we will focus on the therapeutic
anabolic development by rabbit then the
first question is why do we choose
rabbit as the hostname animal for the
animal development
a desired antibody should have a high
affinity and high specificity which
rabbit is able to satisfy by its nature
in this figure more than one thousand
maybe were evaluated with affinity by
spr analysis
and the result shows that the kd value
of rabbits map is mostly around 10 to
minus 10 and 10 to minus 11
even 10 to -12 however the affinity of
mouse and miab is usually lower around
10 to minus 8 and ten to minus nine that
is to say the rabbit's monoclonal
antibody performs vital affinity when
compared to most molecules and body the
secrets of rabbit have higher affinities
meaning due to its
unique and robust immune system
except anti-independent visa modulation
in bone marrow and
anti-dependent visa majority in spring
or lymphocytes rabbit has a special
secondary anti-independent visceral
motivation in gacha which only occurs in
rabbit and bird
additionally rabbit has a longer
evolutionary distance with human
antigens share highly homology between
human at most could also give a better
immune response in rabbits but not in
mice
moreover the larger
because of the larger body size except
the spleen we can also obtain immune as
the b cells from lymphocytes
portfolio blood and bone marrow since
most of the mice
were used in life were obtained by
inbreeding rabbits was remaining in
breathing would also give wider
antigenic
recognitions of the antigen immunization
here is the table compare the rabbit and
the mouse molecular antibody acceptance
the higher affinity due to the special
secondary b cell modulation there is
only one ac sub entity subtype of rabbit
the signal compound is very conserved
the susceptible rate of antibody
sequencing is reality relatively high
and the antibody sequence engineering is
is more easier
also one additional therefore said
that phosphate band exists in rabbit hd
giving a more stable characterization of
rabbit monochrome antibody but it is
also caused a challenge for the
following feminization humanization of
the
rabbit mab
additionally the habit of dragonation
ability of
monoclonal antibody is about 5 times
higher than that of mass there are more
than 5 isotope isotype of cd1
molecule the antigen protein molecules
for lipid saccharide and others molecule
therefore antigens especially small
molecules like saccharides glycolytic
glycolipids and so on can also have
better immunization performance in
rabbit
rabbit is also used to
is also preferred to be used for
developing mouse human and cellular
models cross-reaction analysis
in the year 2019 fda approved the first
humanness and cfa anabolic drug derived
from rabbits
this is the this is the this animal drug
would for the treatment of white md and
this drug was owned by novartis
due to the hiffinity of rabbits mab the
delivery dosage and treatment frequency
of animal drug were both improved
in in the year 2020 the first humanized
full-length java time ap drug was
approved by fda
it is a cgrp blocker for migration
probation
this is the first
full-length rabbit mab was used for
anti-anabolic drug treatment
this message gave us a very exciting and
promising signal that fullness rapid
time a b can also be used for
therapeutic
up to now at least three human is the
rabbit maybe drug are in clinical phase
two and several eye clinical phase one
such as
the antibody against the cd40 however
the humanization of rabbits may be still
important
but in the late future we believe that
we definitely could get through and
enjoy the benefits of rabbit time may be
for antibody drug discovery
because
the
because of the the
advantages such as lower dosage decrease
the driver frequency and
weaker of targets
the development route of each annual
driver is very long then we have to
struggle some ways
finding the most fast and latest
technology to support and accelerate the
antibody development
the main pain point for the animal drug
discovery pipeline is the hemline
with the container with
canine continuous innovation and efforts
now we have successfully established the
rabbit the rapid antibody discovery
platform and the faster high throughput
protein and animal expression plus
purification platforms
then let's have a general comparison
between the classic platform and our
rapid platform for molecular antibody
development
traditional step is in this figure and
the process includes immunization
sufficient and screening and subplonium
and antibody expression
then for each step
what we can what we have done to
accelerate to accelerate the process
firstly we developed a
expressed immunization method and we can
finish this imagination within one month
and secondly followed by v-style
enrichment the primary b cells will be
captured for about 10 days in vivo
individual and the function of the
security and body will be screened
directly by
primary b cell supernatants and this
cultural process will only take two
weeks
thirdly we will deliver anabolic
sequence instead of the hyperdoma cells
so we can use transcendent pressure or
stable cellular generation in a
mammalian cell line with our fast
protein expression platform to obtain
the purified antibody as soon as
possible
in total about
five to seven months will be needed for
antibody development with fusion method
but with our advances advance the
technology we only need
2.5 months
and for immunization we have multiple
strategies to solve different types of
antigen we can use recombinant proteins
and synthetic peptides as immunogen for
entities we cannot get purified protein
such as gpcr targets we can use d or mri
for rabbits and mass emulation and also
we can use the oral press the stable
cell line and the biopsy as as the
immunization material to obtain a good
simulation pattern
we now have established two rabbit
molecular antibodies development
platforms
first one first one is the b-cell
cloning method and the other one is the
single b-cell platform based on beacon
to save time all these two methods are
fusion-free methods
for b-cell cloning method the first step
is
animal immunization if the emelogene is
protein or peptides with high antigenic
we we suggest to use the phenix
immunization method which we which only
take
four weeks for the imagination and
once the emulation was uh was
done
if the serum have committed the criteria
for the animal development we will
collect some portfolio blood for the
rabbit pbmc will be isolated from the
blood and used for the antenna b cell
enrichment
we will directly culture the enriched b
cells with the 96 well plates and the
culture kind of and we can culture the
primary b cells in vitro for about
10 days
we will evaluate if the antibodies
secreted with the b cyclone it's
positive to the antigen or not with
elasta which has through production of
phase given more we will extend the
culture of the primary cells in another
two days and more than one many nature
children could be
collected for further antibody
validation such as the uh thanks the igc
uh and the icc
and after
uh serial after uh essay
and after the
different assets of animal validation we
can further move the positive clones
into the animal sequencing step
and after anabolic sequence
sequencing we will obtain the variable
region of the heaven chain and latching
of the parental clone and if more than
one variable chain and letter chain
was obtained from the printer clone we
will do recombination expression of all
the variable regions of the bear and
page
and we will collect the supernatants of
the recombination and body and for
further validation by the
uh constraining
the depositive and the negative
screening of the antibody
exactly to say the anabolic sequencing
we delivered was the validated
sequencing
and we can finish all the process uh you
know
in industry leading time
the 11 weeks
for beacons the single b cell platform
the animal immunization and the
arrangement of the b-cell is just as
similar to that in pizza cloning the
different step is the anabolic screening
the enriched b cell will be directly
located on the chip after cell
stimulation this is an enlarged view of
the
of a part of the chip there are over ten
thousand nanowires of one chip the
machine can recognize the single b cell
and then pay into every now well of the
chip
the functional acids will be conducted
on chip such as bead-based and always
pressure cell line-based anti-impulsive
aces
after the validation of the single b
cell the desired cells with specific id
will be exported into ionized buffer and
a single b cell will move to engine
sequencing to obtain the value region of
the verb the verb region of the latin
and the human chain
also experiment process can be observed
by beacon the very region of latitude
and hygiene can be guaranteed from the
same single b cell that is to say the
verb region of letter chain and
having chain was natively paired
and then i will take a foreign bb as a
case study to review more details of
these two processes
4mbp also called cd133
it is a tumor analysis factor and widely
impressed on dc active monocytes and
ending cells
the major biological lagging for mbbl is
is is expressed on the activated antigen
proceeding cells the abc cells including
dc cells and macrophages as well as b
cells
location of volume bb active f comma b
and memcanic signal pathways finally
contribution to the segregation of r 2
and f gamma
f and gamma
and
of regulation of bcl bcl-2 family
members bcl excel
therefore foreign bbb
adjunies
agonies offer an audio candidate from
monoclonal antibody therapeutic target
there are four modes of oxygen types of
ants of antiform bb cell
first
agonist agonistic antiform bb might
serve induce t sound proliferation and
set an acetylcholine segregation
and
second on nk styles stimulation of 5bb
can enhance adccc and third agonistic
agonistic anti-foreign baby
mav can also stimulate dc and macrophage
to induce anti-tumor immune response and
also
foreign expressed in the tumor
associated muscular endothelium cells
and the fourth one is
um foreign
can be function as one part of the bowel
specific
antibodies
um such as
bio-specific antibodies targeting both
for mbb and tumor antigens such as her2
can lock immune effectors and target
cells in closely
how to know more than 100 patterns are
prevalent for focusing on foreign bb
target including abl george and others
from 30 companies multiple foreign bb
targets about specific antibodies are in
pre-clinical or early clinical
development and i have demonstrated
promising early data
pharmdb is a transmembrane transmembrane
protein and it's it extra extracellular
domain has
163
amino acids for antibody departments due
to
due to a high homology of
samuel zeno and human
it is easier to obtain double positive
antibodies
because only 57 percent homology is
between human and mouse so it's
it is will be a little bit challenging
to obtain
antibodies with cross reaction of these
three species
for animal discovery
for this project we use purified form
bbe cd as the immunology for rabbit
immunization and
we want to we want to try to obtain a
hierarchy anabolic antibodies with three
species cross reaction the human
semologours and the most
expressed the innovation method was used
for this project we finished the
innovation within one month and after
that we collected
a 30 milliliter portfolio blood from two
rabbits and pulled the pbm together for
bizarre arrangement to increase the b
cell diversity
with the b sound cloning method we
obtained more than 100 electro-positive
clones with the
protein and after the confirmation of
the files with the ovary pressure always
press the cell line we obtained 43 um
double quotative
clones that is
positive to over the press the human and
standard for mbb
and at last we obtained nine uh parental
clones um false
shows three uh space cross reactions
um
these nine clones was positive to human
standard and the most for mbv over
expresses our line
to further
um and to further
confirm of for the further form of the
anabolic diversity we
moved
the
107
positive clients for indians sequencing
and after the indian sequencing we do
the sequence analysis for its um
voice diversity and the peak
unit clones for further android
expression and the 43 clones for animal
was used for the antibody transcendent
impression and we collected the
supernatant and do the further
validation of the
recombinants antibodies
and
in the end 33 clients was
still positive with both the land and
the france validation
and for beacon platform
after one round of
uh as a anime as a positive screening we
obtained more than one thousand positive
clients
and
also when we uh when we some form we
will always press uh human
foreign as the uh screening material we
identify uh
over 200 positive clones that have
binding affinity with binding activity
with the always pressed the
foreign bb cell line and we pick 50
clients for the nds sequencing and after
the angular sequencing we obtained 31
clients letter words that can
successfully
pair
paired with the visual bl
and this is the narrow down process to
obtain our target antibodies where b
cell cloning method after b cell culture
we firstly screened the supernatant with
4mbp protein by elisa and then in fact
was used to
the for further for
confirmation of the uh supernatant with
the always present cell line
all these scientists we were performing
with the primary b-style supernatant
that is the most advantage of our uh
of our platform we can know uh which
clones was the most uh shows the most
promising uh data of uh which column is
our targeting clone and then we will we
can move this uh promising clone with uh
for the further animal sequencing to
save time and cost and this is some
fixed uh fixed example uh when we get
these results from the bestowed
supernatant
we can see that um
just with the b cell supernatural would
have we can identify if this plant glow
was supportive to a different kind of
squirrel new material
and to check this is the detailed
detail and for the sequencing results
to check the antibody diversity and
chose the unique sequence for further
anabolic expression we applied the nds
sequencing for all these
117 electron potential clones we analyze
the similarity of the antibodies and the
sequence between each clone
and
from the result we can see that only 5
clones show identical variable sequence
the genetic trait analysis can help us
pick the unit clones for further
expression
and moreover we can
uh we can do more analysis for the
antibody push
take these
two figures as an example we can know
how many germlines were obtained in this
project and the gemini analysis can do a
favor
can do a favor folder for the
humanization
and from this below two fingers we can
get in for information about the cdr
length of each body then we can pick
candidates with
which can meet the different criteria
for the further android development
um and we then pick up 43 clones for
anybody gene senses and we want to see
the uh recombinant several rate of the
indian sequencing and
we want to get the purified
antibody for the further functional
validation
the recombination antibodies should can
center function with that of primary b
cells we tested the
we recombined uh
we recommended of all these uh 43 clones
and after the validation with the
recombination supernatant um
we got 33
positive clients still with eliza and
both facts validation and the successful
rate of the recombination is around 17.
70
percent
and then we uh we
take one clone as the
sample to show
that the recombination ant body still
still shows the
uh affinity planting activity with the
three different overexpression cell
lines the human form bb cell line
synonymous cell line and both the moles
from the cell line
uh
this slide shows the dto assets we
conducted on chip as a beacon platform
this about figure is for the uh b-space
anti-impulsive screening and the an
engine will be labeled with belting and
was
incubated with the as a conjugated beast
and and then the antigen will be
coated with the bees and
to identify if the antibodies segregated
simple b cells with positive to this
antigen we will load this icy
acids
onto the chip
in the inner channel
and
we will take photos at different time
points and then the the beacon will
form
a video and from this video we can know
which b cells with specific id number is
our targeted b cells and after the
functional uh screening we finally got
more than one thousand uh and hidden
piece positive heads
and the below figure is the surface the
ac
when we use the always pressure cell
line with our target antigen instead of
the acids
we can
know we can know the secreted antibody
by the single b cells was the cell
southland binding positive or not
and after this uh cell life functional
screening we finally got more than one
hundred
and
seven protein
um
keys
and then we selected the 30 double
protein clones for indian sequencing to
open to obtain the antibodies frequency
and
and analyze the diversity of the
antibodies derived from beaking we can
see that uh out of 31 clones uh shows uh
out of 31 31 clients four clones show
the identical uh variable region of
having chain with the other clones and
two clones show the identical uh
variable region of of latching with
other other clones
and
uh
the successful rate of the any
sequencing is a little bit lower
compared with the b-cell cloning because
the sequencing is uh is for the single b
cell uh single b cell the uh the amount
will be relatively lower uh
the the amount of the amine will be
relatively lower compared with the
bizarre cloning and
from this case we can know that
the successful rate of sequence of
parent sequencing is around
30 percent
um because uh because in the pixel
cloning method uh the the cells can be
closed into um
one single one b cell clone and this
column contains more than one solid
b cells so the successful rate of b
cyclonic is
nearly 1 000 percent
and this is the different the the
antibodies sequencing rate so cell phone
rate is a little bit different between
these two methods
and
recommendations
after the anabolic sequencing
and
after we obtained the antibodies
sequencing
another important step is the
feminization between we can
do some
functional
screen screening
as for the pre-clinical study
and especially for rabbit the
humanization is very special and
critical
um
another feature of uh and therefore
our company have developed a very
special platform for documentation it is
the ai-based technology and the general
workflow is that we will use the
selected template human policies against
the human database and then
use bioinformatics strategy to harmonize
the antibodies frequency after the human
nation generated by the um
by generated by
ai
and uh after the
humanization a large uh anabolic
sequencing pool will be obtained
um so for the candidate humanist and
foreign to how can we do
uh
selection for
uh for the
best
humanist animal sequencing um to answer
this question we will use the
also use the ai-based
uh recommendation um
ranking and then we will select top 10
hormones and body form the recombination
and
after the recombination of the humanist
antibody we will collect the supernatant
and
do
validation of some
antibody um
with elasta binding pending method and
we can know if the
human rabbit molecular antibody was
still positive to the entity or not we
can use eliza uh
thanks or other methods for the
confirmation and after the validation of
the bending affinity
of the binding activity between the
entity and humanist rabbits
and maybe we will further we can further
measure the
kd value of the humanness antibody with
the full bio
biac method
and the the advantages
of the combination in our platform is
that because we use the ai
ai sentence method for the whole process
so the uh turrent time
and the
under the searching skill scopes
will be
will be
maximum maximumly
saved
as we know that the rabbit molecule
antibodies have many specific
characterizations different from mouse
and human the most important point is
the 1780 and the verb region of the
latter chain
on the constant region the setting 171
can form a deposit band with this 1780
therefore during the humanization the
council region will be replaced with a
human sequence and there is no setting
171
and the deposit deposit the band of the
1380 will be free then these three 1780s
need to be mutated into other amino
acids except at this point the ef loop
the d loop and the thirteen pairs also
should be in consideration to the
humanization
we have developed the rabbit molecular
antibody human regime and these are
spirons as results of our molecular
antibodies before and after humanization
before the humanization the kidney value
is about tend to manage team and after
humanization the key value is around
five times to ten to minus nine
definitely is reduced about fifty fold
and uh during the antibiotic discovery
another important step is to develop
anti-id antibodies which is commonly
used for
pharmacokinetic analysis in pre-clinic
pre-clinical practice
pk study is the most important step
during the
is most important
for the drug metabolism throughout the
body such as
like to determine the rate of drug
absorption distribution and
excretion
in virus cohorts
our researchers need to be able to track
anybody drugs which are bound or
unbounded to their design target at a
various
time point post delivery to achieve this
same entity blocking and antigen
non-blocking anybody enhancing anybody
should be developed
for the peaky
analysis
and we have rich experience on any
project and this figure is a case study
of developing blocking antibodies
we
firstly obtained more than 100 clients
positive tools immunogen and this
particular
and then we uh we further confirmed this
particular clones with the
constraining material because the ntid
antibody was will be finally used
on the detection of the antibody drug
in the human theorem so
the clients do not want the antibodies
shows the cause reaction with the human
serum so we use the document hd as a
consequent material and after the uh the
confirmation we can see that more than
one hundred polyclones will still uh
still exist and this clones was positive
to the emerging for the full length and
uh
fiber of the angular drug and
do not
can
cannot uh cross reaction with um toluca
mygg and for this project because the
the class want to generate a blocking
ant body so
after the
the banning of the of the
anthenyan body with the animal drug will
do a complete complicated lesson to the
selective blockers for the class and
finally we obtain them 11 clients that
shows higher blocking activity between
the anabolic drug and lagging
after the leader generation the
following question is how can we
evaluate the drug safety
we can provide pk and adidas development
to measure anabolic drug concentration
in different metrics such as serum and
neural with high sensitive sensitivity
in a larger linear range
we can also provide the hcp case
development
for the measurements of the protein of
the host cells that be used for the
antibody expression for all the kid
projects we could offer from raw
development to generate grade production
in summary we have established the
highly customized scalable total
antibody drug discovery solutions at
different stages including both northern
minnesota gene and private synthesis
virus packaging anabolic development and
leader generation animal production and
kids development
now genescript is a world-leading
biology cl company with more than 5 000
employees serving more than 30 thousand
customers from more than 100 countries
we have more than 18 years influence of
animal development and have delivered
more than one hundred fifty thousand and
four projects we have the most latest
technologies to maximize your success
the your success at achieving high
quality antibodies and also
for the ownership and the
are totally owned by customer for the
discovered antibody
my presentation will stop here and it's
our pleasure to share the animal
discovery story of ours we're more than
happy to be a part of you and speed up
your research
thank you dr dean for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
what do you mean about the alac and ola
animal facilities
um thank you for this question and uh i
i will answer in 14 words
and always short for office of
laboratory animal welfare and
certificates by dhcs and ih eus
and the ola provides guidance and
interpretation of the public health
service
on human care and the use of laboratory
animals and the ola also supports
educational programs and monitors
complaints with the policy to ensure the
human care and the use of the animals in
phi as valid research testing and
training and the a like is the full name
of association for assessment and
accreditation of laboratory animal care
it is a non-governmental and nonprofit
international certification of the
organization and uh
and it is also the certification for
animal breeding and and animal related
improvements
uh the analytics require uh centrifugal
treatment of animals in the fields of
biological science and medicine in order
to ensure and promote the quality of
animal appearance the u.s
fda and the europe commitment strongly
document animal experience
was conducted in like
certificated laboratories
and in summary
in the united states if you uh if you
come from the united states and want to
apply some projects
from it by the nih fd or cdc maybe the
ola certification is required for the
animal facility and the e-link is a
global certification organization for
animal welfare requirements and this is
my answer for this question and welcome
to more patchy
all right thank you
next question
how to compare two different rabbit
maybe and developing technologies single
b cell and b-cell cloning
as i have
presented during the webinar
um
for the b-cell enrichment and
the animal intelligence just that
seminars
in both in both single b and b cell
cloning method and the main difference
is
about the animal screenings
step
for the beacon platform um
we because we call it the single b sound
so the most uh
so uh the most advantage is that the
other action although as i said
implement can be
conducted at the single b sound level uh
so the biggest very most uh
comprehensive machine
for the function to determine the
function of the circuit and body um and
the digital enzymes the cells can be
penetrating to every nanowire and
the single b cell was can be observed
before and after the cells were
dependent into the non-well
and also we can do the function
screening on the chip after the painting
was done
we can both use the antenna will be the
base the antidepressant energy and also
we can use cell line to identify if the
antibody was cellular potential for cell
and binding uh anybody
um and we can do uh cyber assets in one
day
for one round of screening maybe 15 to
30 minutes will cost
and um
and that is to say uh we can do at least
three to five rounds of ic screening on
the chip
in one day and
so it is a very comprehensive machine
and
because the
before and after the b sound
screening
all the experiment can be observed so we
can guarantee the vowel region of the
legend uh having change was
come from the
same b sound
means that it means the vowel region of
large hand haven't changed was natively
paired
but for bisa cloning because we cultured
the b cells
in virtual
after the b cell arrangement and
we
dilute the b cells with the serial
dilution method due to this method
limitation
we want we want most of the vowels was a
single b cell clone but
after the
growth of the culture of some b sounds
maybe more than one clone
will obtain
um
so
maybe more than one very verbal region
of having channel live chain will be
obtained
but
but we will do randomly the combination
of this all these
vibrate
variation rail and do validation from
the recommended
supernatant
um so
even though we cannot observe
that the average and val was from the
single b south um but
because the
uh we want to maximizely uh guarantee
the
the cells was a single b cell clone so
um we can
um
relatively interested that the uh the
variable region of legend i have two was
natively paired but
um if you uh sensitive to this point
maybe became well recommended
and that's this is the answer for this
question
all right thank you
next question
what other antibody characterization can
gen script perform
false antibodies screening um elastin
the fine system is uh was the most
used method for for the analysis
screening except the exception for this
tool has to put the screening method we
can also do uh other functional
validation screenings such as
the cell-based
lasagna and the surface scientist these
two methods can help us to
to
find the
suitable uh clones that can uh
application
application in the
uh ifc and also we can provide the icc
and there will be ip product and
so on and some other assets
to select
positive clones that's suitable for your
application
and with the purified protein
if we
express the antibody and
after the purification of somebody we
can use the antibody
um
we can use the hplc mass
for the quantity control and if you want
to measure the
kd value uh the affinity of the
employees we can perform the finite
environment with
uh football or the vr called the
bi or spr methods
all right that's on all right
next question
what are the key advantages of choosing
gen scripts antibody services
oh thank you thank you for this question
and
i think that there are some
uh there are truly some advantages that
help you to choose thin script as the
first choice
um the first
maybe the first
point is that uh we can provide to one
uh one stop solution from gn pipette
since that is protein depression
antibody uh discovery to lead a little
validation even the uh gmp live rocket
production um because we are a very
comprehensive one-stop solution see our
company
and the second is that
um
because because of the fifa service
model for the
customized service
all the
ip
of the ownership of the project
deliveries such as the animated
sequencing
was totally owned by uh
and
also from the uh from the history and
milestone we can see that we have uh
rich appearance
um on the
biology reagent
products
development and also the antibody
development we we have more than 18
years experience and have uh finished
more than 150 thousand projects in total
and also as i have answered in the first
question we have the elec and ola double
certificated animals facility
um and uh for the technology we have the
level uh
uh developed um
uh the some
self-developed and
most latest uh uh platforms to support
uh the
uh the
the basic research and to
maximize your successful rates
for example we have the
coding uh coding optimization
tools and the unhinging design tools to
have
to
increase the uh protein or animal
expression level and also to design the
best antigen uh that can suit or can be
used for inhalation
um and also if the homology is
very high for example even 100 percent
between hormone mass we have the
immunoplastic
technology to break the tolerance for
the immune immunization and also as
joined in the
webinar um
the turnaround time of our um
of our service
for the animal development or the
protein production with the the toronto
is as short is
industry leading time i think
and
uh
also except the single b sound the
beacon platform and the bizarre cloney
we also have other animal development
strategies such as the traditional
hybrid hybridoma fusion method and the
feed display measured
um and
i think this is always a good
summary for this question if if you want
to learn more i think you can
you can contact us daily or find some
information from our website
all right great thank you
next question
is a four-week immunization in rabbits
adequate in all cases
um
so okay can you address it
is a four-week immunization in rabbit
adequate in all cases
oh thank you for the question um
the the four weeks simulation is our
self development method um
for rabbits the express the processes
will uh the whole process will take uh
four weeks and for
um
and the the proceed uh the the the whole
process was uh
was previous uh previously uh settled
down um we will uh that if the first
injection was given to the animal uh
other uh all the timeline will be sadhus
following the first injection and
also we have i want to say here we have
some
expressed
emulation method for
most and it will only take two weeks
all right great
next question
in addition to affinity will other
factors such as heterogeneity be
considered for choosing the top clones
um
yes
i know that's the uh the high uh
successful rate
of the productive clone is good but also
it is a little bit challenging uh
challenging for uh class when the facing
so uh plenty party from our
anabolic pool they want to know which uh
clone was the best for their dumb
application so
my outside
accepts the affinity
may be um you should uh consent about
most looking uh concerns about your diet
application uh for example if you want
to generate a
hsc
antibody um for um for the
for the in vitro detection uh except his
affinity maybe the uh low um background
should be considered so
we can
do some constraining during the
during the animal department
and uh for the animal drug development
because most of the uh the
the antibodies
was
will be um will be used in the clinical
clinic uh clinical experiments maybe you
want um a very low cross reaction of the
ant body with the metrics such as
the human or animal serum um so
except the affinity maybe we can add the
serum as the consonant material and
i mean
to to narrow down the animal animal too
um
and if you want to
detect
some
small molecule or some
some proteins during the
metabolism
so the sensitivity of the parry ant body
should be considered so you you should
uh
we will see like to
we will do some uh for example epitopin
to help you
select the antibodies that can
recognize more than one epitope so
it can increase the successful rates to
obtain the paradigm body for the samurai
laser
for some
individual diagnostic detection
so i think maybe
for to narrow down the anabolic pool
except the affinity you should
consider more about the application
all right
thank you
next question
generally how many top clones are
recommended since for single b cloning
over 100 clones are possible
um
from the uh the case study i have joined
um the more than one thousand uh
political clones will be uh
obtained after the
uh one round of uh screening on one chip
um but the uh the the export of the of
the cells so it will uh every every um
everything will be sound will cost about
three minutes so the limitation of the
beacon platform is not just a part of
his is about the x export time so
um we will recommend you to
export
the top 100 or even 200 clones
to the unless the buffer
but how can we select
this top uh 100 from this uh so lens of
particles maybe we can
uh take uh we can design uh more acids
uh to narrow down the particles um for
example um after the accepts the
antidepressant screening um we can uh we
can narrow down supportive case with the
cell line obvious pressure cell line
screening or some blocking acid
screening um and in the end maybe
we can recommend you to export
the
uh about 100 to or less than 500
clones to the unless it's buffer
all right thank you
next question
what's our success rate so far for
anti-id
anti-id projects
and how many unique clones do you expect
um
that's the most the frequent question we
will be asked
for from class
as um
uh in generally uh most of uh class
maybe think that uh it is more easier to
obtain um
land blocking than non-blocker or
non-blocking antibody um
for the detection of
the total antibody drive but
according to our experiments um we have
fini uh and
this year we have finished more than 50
projects of the uh
unhid projects um and the successful
rates of the blockchain body is very
high all of the projects that we
successfully
delivered the blocking antibody uh that
it means uh 100 societies for the
blocking antibody department um but
for the land blocker
because the anti-id antibody was mostly
used for the
pharmacokinetic analysis the peaking
analysis
so
the matrix will be
complicated um status
as um animal serum or human serum so uh
total himalay or todokimanjiji one or
four will be needed for the screening we
do not want the idea anybody have any uh
cross reaction with um
with the uh when we
detected the anabolic drug um
uh in the uh
uh serum or
urine uh matrix
um
so after the constraining most of the of
our unhealthy antibodies that can
recognize the concentration
of the beverage of the fr
will be excluded
so the remaining antibodies um will be
partially or
100
blocker antibody for
this project
so for such projects the
anybody it's a little bit difficult the
success variety is a little bit lower um
up to now we have uh there were three
projects with the failed to uh obtained
and had the number nine blocking any
anybody
so the successful rate of blocking
anybody is 100
and
for the non-blocking anybody
it will be a little bit lower and
difficult
all right thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question
will cryo preservation of pbmc affect
the efficiency of getting positive
cloning
um
yeah yeah uh thank you for this question
um
from the workflow we can see that we use
the portfolio blood uh collided from
the rabbit because the process is very
large
have for the pizza cloning um but they
fuel uh if the immunization was not done
in our company we also can accept the
start uh stored um
b cells tbmc cells or even spleen uh
splenocesce um
glass and but if the initial uh material
is not fresh pbm will see maybe the
sample rates will be a little bit lower
according to our
comparison uh data uh we uh we get the
congruent that the the several the
positive rates will be
50 percent will be around 50 percent
that's
that is to say about half of the
um
positive clone will be lost uh due to
the
uh the southwest starlings and liquid
nitrogen and
salt into the
room temperature uh the cell culture
temperature so
the savage will be
15
uh compared with the fresh pbmc
all right
thank you dr dean do you have any final
comments for our audience
um
yes
uh the therapeutic antibodies have
become the predominant class of new
drugs diplomacy in recent years i think
the
the most uh most of the clients
want to
consent most is the time timeline uh the
timeline is always the pin point during
this process
and with our mission of
genescript we want to make she points
nature healthier throughout
technology we have uh integrated to a
series of process and consensus scalable
solution to facilitate each prince
principle milestones in
animal drug discovery we will provide a
very high speed and quality um antibody
discovery
uh process
towards nd and
today we take foreign bb as a case study
to show our
uh ability to show what can we do to
support your work
so uh here i want to thank you again for
everyone to attend this
webinar today and
i hope to work with you soon to support
your project
well thank you again dr ding for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor genscript for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you